-Oh, I should have left that
backstage.
Hey, everybody.
I was at the doctor
the other day and he told me,
"Joe, if you don't start
eating right and exercising,
I'm gonna have to put you
on medication."
And I said,
"Just give me the medication.
I'm not gonna do that now that I
know about the medication.
You shouldn't have told me
about the medication."
[ Laughter ]
By now you're realizing
I have a higher-pitched voice
than most men.
That's a burden that Mike Tyson
and I share together.
[ Laughter ]
I went to
a fast-food drive-through.
The person on the other end of
the microphone heard my voice
and thought I was female.
I pulled around
to pick up my Baconator,
and he still called me ma'am.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't even correct him.
I figured what's worse?
A stranger thinking I'm female
when I'm male
or having to persuade...
[ Laughter ]
...another man
that I'm also a man.
[ Laughter ]
I won't do it.
I've had that conversation
too many times.
And too many times
they were not persuaded.
I told a female friend that,
and she said,
"Well, what do you think
is worse?
A person thinking you're
a female when you're male
or pregnant when you're not?"
And I said, "Well, both have
happened to me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Neither made me feel
very good."
[ Laughter ]
But did remind me of a story
when I went to Disney World
a couple years back.
There's a thing there
called the Fast Pass.
That's where you can pay more
to cut in line,
but what they don't tell you is
when you cut at amusement parks
it's overwhelmingly children
that you're cutting in front of.
[ Laughter ]
So I bought one.
Went to the roller coaster,
used my Fast Pass,
and realized I enjoy the cutting
way more than
any of the stupid rides.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It got to the point
I wouldn't even bother
getting on the rides.
I would just go to
the front of the line
and then loop back around to cut
in front of more children.
[ Laughter ]
At one point a child said,
"Daddy, why can he go
in front of us?"
And I said, "I make more money
than your father does."
[ Laughter and applause ]
He said, "Daddy, that's
the meanest pregnant lady
I've ever seen."
[ Laughter ]
I read that the Drug Enforcement
Agency is gonna crack down hard
on NFL doctors over painkillers
and performance-enhancing drugs.
I don't think they should.
I would take steroids on purpose
just so I don't have to play
football.
[ Laughter ]
Because steroids
are safer than football.
[ Laughter ]
Doctor's like, "Joe, you tested
positive for steroids.
That means you're not allowed to
be tackled over and over again
by a 6'4", 300-pound man
who's also on steroids."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Well, gee, Doc,
that sounds bad.
What are the steroids gonna do?"
He's like, "well, they're gonna
give you
a deeper voice
and smaller testicles."
I'm like, "I could use
both of those things."
[ Laughter ]
"Scratch me
right where I itch, Doc."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I do a lot of traveling
for stand-up.
On a recent flight though,
a lady had her dog
in the middle seat,
and she bragged to me that she
bought a fake service dog vest
on the Internet.
Now she takes her dog
everywhere,
and I thought
that was a little off-putting.
And she explained to me
that technically her dog
cheers her up,
so in a way it is
an emotional-support dog.
I thought, "Yeah, but what dog
doesn't cheer you up?"
If your dog
doesn't cheer you up,
you should check to see
if your dog is a cat.
[ Laughter ]
Because cats
are the number-one reason
you would need
an emotional-support dog.
[ Laughter ]
They call those ladies
crazy cat ladies,
but they weren't crazy
before they had a whole bunch of
pets that didn't love them back.
[ Laughter ]
Got a weird call
from my bank, gang.
They said that my security
questions were hacked again,
and they recommended that I
change the answers immediately.
I replied,
"Well, how does that work?
How can I change the answers
to facts about myself?"
[ Laughter ]
What's your favorite band?
Led Zeppelin. Not anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Now it's the Backstreet Boys.
My security questions
have been hacked so many times
I have my regular personality
and an alter-ego
I had to write down
so I could remember what I said
was true about myself.
[ Laughter ]
In my regular life
I enjoy Sprite
and "Battlestar Galactica."
Ask the Internet,
it's cocaine and cage fighting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Joe Machi, everybody.
Hey, nice to see you.
You should have left that
backstage.
Follow him on Twitter @Joemachi.
My thanks to Jason Momoa,
J.K. Simmons,
Joe Machi once again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was great.
You deserve it, buddy.